Ben Brock Johnson from Endless Thread. Roman Mars from 99% Invisible. Today we're bringing you the third episode from our series, Hidden Levels, all about how the world of video games has changed the world beyond video games. Speaking worlds, how familiar are you with the e-sports world? Like, familiar enough to tell you a definition, but not like steeped in it in any mean. meaningful way. You're not following evil geniuses or fanatic or cloud nine. You're not following these teams. No, I wouldn't say that I am. I don't know. I mean, I know that you're saying English words,
我是来自《无穷之线》的本·布罗ック·约翰逊。我是来自《99%隐形》的罗曼·马尔斯。今天我们为您带来我们系列节目“隐藏关卡”的第三集，主要讲述电子游戏世界如何改变了游戏之外的世界。说到世界，你对电竞世界有多熟悉？比如说，熟悉到能说出一个定义，但并没有真正深入其中。你并没有关注过邪恶天才、Fnatic或者Cloud9。你没有关注这些战队。不，我不会说我很了解。我不知道。我的意思是，我知道你在说一些英语词汇，
but I have no idea what those things are. So for the uninitiated e-sports is basically organized competitive gaming. Think of all the fanfare sponsorship, stadiums, tension of your favorite sports league. But instead of dribbling a ball or swinging a racket, e-sports competitors are playing multi-person video games for titles, often in front of very large live audiences. And I know this has been big. And down goes nights once again when you need someone, when you need anyone to stand up and show just what this game's all about. And I know this has been big for a while, but at this point, how many people beyond the stadium are watching people play games? I will say, Roman, I was shocked by this.
但我完全不知道那些是什么。对于外行人来说，电竞基本上就是有组织的竞技游戏。想象一下你最喜欢的体育联赛中的所有狂热、赞助、体育场和紧张气氛。但电竞选手们不运球也不挥拍，而是在进行多人电子游戏比赛以争夺冠军，通常是在非常大的现场观众面前。我知道这已经规模很大了。当你需要某个人，当需要任何人站出来展示这个游戏的真正意义时，奈茨再次落败。我知道这已经火了一段时间了，但现在，在体育场外有多少人在看别人打游戏？我得说，罗曼，我对此感到震惊。
The global e-sport audience is expected to exceed 600 million this year. This is an industry worth more than a billion dollars. Average competitor is in their 20s, and you actually age out in your 20s of being able to play because you can't click a mouse fast enough after that to compete. So I'm not going to go pro? No, Roman, I'm sorry. You can't go pro.
今年全球电竞观众预计将超过6亿美元。这是一个价值超过十亿美元的产业。平均选手年龄在20多岁，实际上你在20多岁时就会因为反应变慢而无法继续打职业，因为你无法再以足够快的速度点击鼠标来竞技。所以我不会成为职业选手？不，罗曼，我很抱歉。你不能成为职业选手。
You can't go pro. You might be able to coach. You'd be a great coach. You can't go pro. So the spectators for e-sports are largely male and can actually even skew younger than the players themselves. So there are a lot of teenagers who watch this stuff and this demographic teenage males
你不能成为职业选手。你或许可以当教练。你会是个出色的教练。你不能成为职业选手。因此，电竞的观众主要是男性，而且他们的年龄甚至比选手本身还要年轻。所以有很多青少年看这些内容，而青少年男性这个群体
is very interesting to a long-standing U.S. organization who needs you. We will let producer Caitlin Harrop take it from here. Picture that. It's 10 a.m. on a Saturday, and you're in a convention center in Philadelphia or Denver. The space is crammed with booths promoting video games like Call of Duty and Halo. You can see an advertisement for G-Fuel and energy formula for gamers. And everywhere you look, there is group after group of young men huddled around gaming demos.
对一个需要你的历史悠久的美国组织来说非常吸引人。我们让制作人凯特琳·哈罗普从这里接管。想象一下。周六上午10点，你在费城或丹佛的一个会议中心。这个空间挤满了推广《使命召唤》和《光环》等电子游戏的展位。你可以看到为游戏玩家准备的能量配方G-Fuel的广告。无论你看到哪里，都是一群又一群的年轻男子聚集在一起观看游戏演示。
As you keep walking, you come across a bank of gaming consoles manned by a crew in tight hairstyles and quick dry jerseys branded with a gold and white star. You found the Army Esports team. Fan Expos is one of our bigger events where we're able to interact with most of the public. And we pretty much bring a 30 by 30 booth. We set up all the games we possibly can, and then we just have genuine conversations with the eventgoers while competing against them and talking a little bit of trash and just having fun.
当你继续走时，你会遇到一排游戏主机，由一群发型紧凑、穿着印有金白相星标志的速干球衣的工作人员管理。你找到了陆军电竞战队。粉丝博览会是我们能够与大部分公众互动的较大活动之一。我们基本上会带一个30乘30英尺的展位。我们尽可能多地设置游戏，然后与活动参与者进行真诚的对话，同时与他们竞技并开点无伤大雅的玩笑，尽情享受乐趣。
That's Staff Sergeant Joseph Edwards. He spent most of his career as an Army intelligence analyst stationed all over the world. Now, he's one of 13 soldiers who has taken on a multi-year assignment, fully devoted to representing the Army in the world of competitive gaming, with one major objective in mind. They want to spread the Army message through the power and passion of gaming and get you interested. in joining up in the process. We kind of start off the conversation with gaming, and then if they're interested, a lot of times they'll ask,
那是约瑟夫·爱德华兹上士。他的大部分职业生涯都是作为驻扎在世界各地的陆军情报分析员度过的。现在，他是13名承担多年任务的士兵之一，全心全意地在竞技游戏世界中代表陆军，心中有一个主要目标。他们希望通过游戏的权力和热情传播陆军的信息，并让你在此过程中对加入产生兴趣。我们通常从游戏开始对话，然后如果他们感兴趣，很多时候他们会问，
are you actually in the Army? And then that kind of opens it up to us being able to tell our Army story, why we joined what we've done so far, all the different opportunities that the Army's provided us. The Army feels it's important to adapt to the culture and to the times,
你们真的是陆军吗？然后这就在某种程度上让我们能够讲述我们的陆军故事，我们为什么加入，我们迄今为止做了什么，以及陆军为我们提供的所有不同机会。陆军认为适应文化和时代非常重要，
to find innovative, new ways to reach potential recruits. And this is important because, For decades, the Army has been on edge about recruitment, hitting their goals for a few years and then missing them again. Recently, the Army missed their recruitment goals in 2022 and 2023. They met them in 2024 after lowering their target by 10,000 from the year before. And as they see it, video games are a great way to connect, live, in person, and online. Members of the Army e-sports team are not technically recruiters themselves,
寻找创新、全新的方法来接触潜在新兵。这很重要，因为几十年来，陆军在招兵方面一直处于紧张状态，招兵目标达成几年后又再次未能达标。最近，陆军在2022年和2023年未能达成招兵目标。在将目标比前一年降低10,000人后，他们在2024年达标了。在他们看来，电子游戏是现场、当面以及在线建立联系的好方法。陆军电竞战队的成员在技术上并不是招募人员，
but they do sit under the Army recruitment division as members of the Army's outreach company. And at any public event, the Army Esports team is accompanied by at least one recruiter. If someone's interested in joining up, that recruiter is ready to step in. Nora Benzahel is a professor of practice at Johns Hopkins School of Advanced international studies. She says that the Army's presence in e-sports builds on a long-standing effort, an effort honed at county fairs and in high school cafeterias, an effort to communicate with young people. The military considers people between ages 17 and 23 to 24 to be the primary target for recruiting. But of course, 17-year-olds don't suddenly decide to start thinking about their
但他们的确隶属于陆军招募部门，作为陆军外展连的成员。在任何公共活动中，陆军电竞战队都至少有一名招募员陪同。如果有人对加入感兴趣，那名招募员随时准备介入。诺拉·本扎赫尔是约翰斯·霍普金斯大学高级国际研究学院的实践教授。她说，陆军在电竞领域的存在建立在长期努力的基础上，这种努力在集市和高中食堂里磨练出来，旨在与年轻人沟通。军方认为17岁到23、24岁之间的人是招募的主要目标。但当然，17岁的青少年不会突然开始考虑他们的
career when they're 17. While recruiters focus on warm contacts, those of recruitment age interested in signing up, Ben Zahel says outreach gets to cast a wider net. So the Army does try to reach out to people who are younger than 17, not to recruit them, not to say come into the Army right now, but because most Americans know nothing about the military. They do try to reach out to people younger than that, to give them information so that it's one of the options that they consider. The Army maintains that they do not target kids under recruitment age with their Army ESports team. But it's also an undeniable fact that many esports spaces where the team can be found, including expos and tournaments, they bring in people of all ages, including spectators
职业生涯。虽然招募人员专注于热线联系，即那些达到招募年龄并有兴趣签约的人，但本扎赫尔表示，外展活动能够撒下更大的网。因此，陆军确实试图接触比17岁更年轻的人，不是为了招募他们，不是为了说现在就加入陆军，而是因为大多数美国人对军队一无所知。他们确实试图接触比这更年轻的人，向他们提供信息，使其成为他们考虑的选项之一。陆军坚称他们不会用陆军电竞战队针对招募年龄以下的儿童。但这也是一个不可否认的事实，即该战队可以被找到的许多电竞场所，包括博览会和锦标赛，吸引了各个年龄段的人，包括
younger than 17. And if these teens and pre-teens are interested in learning more about the Army, the Army e-sports team is ready to connect. Captain Mimi Mejia, commander of the Army's outreach company, which oversees e-sports, describes this dynamic as, quote,
比17岁还年轻的观众。如果这些青少年和儿童有兴趣更多地了解陆军，陆军电竞战队随时准备建立联系。监督电竞的陆军外展连连长米米·梅希亚上尉将这种动态描述为，引用一句话，
planting a seed. Is there like a youngest age that folks talk to or see at these events? There's no minimum age, I would say. a recruiter themselves isn't going to start talking to anyone until they're at least a freshman in high school. But the e-sports team does pretty well connecting with kids that are younger than that just because those kids still play games too. So if a young kid sees a guy that they really respect wearing the U.S. Army logo and they continue to see that over their time in middle
播下一颗种子。人们在这些活动中交谈或看到的最小年龄是多少？我想说没有最低年龄。招募人员本身不会开始与任何人交谈，直到他们至少是高一新生。但电竞战队在与比这更年轻的孩子建立联系方面做得相当不错，因为这些孩子也玩游戏。因此，如果一个小孩子看到一个他们非常尊敬的人穿着美国陆军标志，并且他们在整个中学时期继续看到这一点
school and high school, then they might start to think about the Army a little bit more. So that's just a seed that we're planning, and especially when they're in middle school, we're not saying join the Army, but we're more so just getting that idea into their heads. It makes sense that the Army would embed itself so deeply in e-sports. Nearly 80% of Americans between 13 and 28 years old place some form of video games on a weekly basis. So gamers, it's a market the Army badly wants, full of young Americans prepped for the technological advancements of the modern battlefield. This approach is not new.
和高中，他们可能会开始更多地考虑陆军。所以这只是我们正在播下的一颗种子，特别是当他们上初中时，我们并不是说加入陆军，而是更多地将这个想法带入他们的脑海中。陆军如此深入地融入电竞是合乎情理的。13岁到28岁之间的美国人中，近80%每周都会玩某种形式的电子游戏。因此，游戏玩家是陆军极力想要的市场，这里满是为现代战场技术进步做好准备的年轻美国人。这种方法并不新鲜。
Decades before military e-sports teams started facing off against civilians, the U.S. Army took its first steps into consumer video games. Finally, in January 1973, the draft is ended and replaced by an all-volunteer military force. When the U.S. Army ended the draft in 73, it was widely seen as good news. news. The U.S. was no longer forcing the majority of young men who couldn't afford to go to college or avoid the draft in other ways to go to war. But it also meant the military needed to majorly step up its outreach efforts, which they did. Campaigns like the Be All You Can Be ads of the 80s were super popular and led to short-term bumps in recruitment. But it didn't
在军事电竞战队开始与平民对决的几十年前，美国陆军就迈出了进军消费类电子游戏的第一步。最终，在1973年1月，征兵制结束，取而代之的是全志愿兵军事部队。当美国陆军在73年结束征兵时，这被广泛视为好消息。美国不再强迫大多数无法承担大学学费或以其他方式逃避征兵的年轻男子去打仗。但这同时也意味着军队需要大幅加强其外展工作，他们确实这样做了。诸如80年代的“做最好的自己”广告这样的活动非常受欢迎，并导致招募人数短期激增。但它并没有
last. The Army failed to meet its recruitment goals in 1998. It failed again in 1999, and folks at the Pentagon began to worry. If war were to break out, U.S. defense could be stretched thin. There's a common understanding that as the economy booms, entry-level pay for soldiers doesn't always keep up with civilian wages, and college attendance goes up, which meant recruitment-age people either already had jobs or they were in school and not so likely to pursue a career in the armed service. They needed a new creative approach to recruitment, one that went beyond TV ads and pull-up contests at the county fair. Enter military economist Casey Wardensky. I have a PhD, so sometimes I go by Dr. Wardensky. I'm retired Army colonel, so sometimes
持续下去。陆军在1998年未能达到招募目标。它在1999年再次失败，五角大楼的人开始担忧。如果爆发战争，美国的防御可能会捉襟见肘。人们普遍认为，随着经济繁荣，士兵的入门薪酬往往跟不上平民工资，大学入学率上升，这意味着达到招募年龄的人要么已经有工作，要么在学校，不太可能追求武装部队的职业生涯。他们需要一种新的创造性招募方法，一种超越电视广告和集市引体向上比赛的方法。军事经济学家凯西·沃登斯基登场。我拥有博士学位，所以有时我被称为沃登斯基博士。我是退役陆军上校，所以有时
I'm Colonel Werdinsky. In 1999, Werdinsky, West Point graduate, Steely Gaze, Strong Jawline, was running the Army's office of economic and manpower analysis. We were very interested in government efficiency, particularly with regard to the Army and how to make the best use of resources. Part of Wardensky's job was to make sure the Army had enough, as his title suggests, manpower. And things weren't looking great. But Wardinsky had an idea, an approach to this recruitment slump that would target not just recruitment age individuals, but the next generation of,
我是沃登斯基上校。1999年，西点军校毕业、目光坚毅、下巴线条硬朗的沃登斯基正在管理陆军的经济和人力分析办公室。我们对政府效率非常感兴趣，特别是在陆军方面以及如何最好地利用资源。沃登斯基的工作之一是确保陆军拥有足够的人力，正如他的头衔所暗示的那样。情况看起来不太妙。但沃登斯基有一个想法，一种解决这次招募低迷的方法，该方法不仅针对招募年龄的个人，还针对下一代的
potential recruits still open to influence as they consider their future. This big idea, as Wardensky saw it, would allow the Army to create their own media image and target future recruits at the same time, a vision born from a very 1990s tradition. The family trip to Best Buy, his two sons in tow. When I was off doing, looking at refrigerators or whatever with my wife, they'd be in the computer game aisle looking at like games that they want to me to buy for them. While the real army was suffering a popularity crisis, battle and first-person shooter games, many based in fictional or intergalactic worlds, were booming.
潜在新兵，他们在考虑未来时仍然容易受到影响。在沃登斯基看来，这个宏大的想法将使陆军能够创造自己的媒体形象，并同时瞄准未来的新兵，这个愿景诞生于一个非常90年代的传统。全家去百思买旅行，他的两个儿子随行。当我不在的时候，和我妻子一起看冰箱或其他东西时，他们会呆在电脑游戏走廊里寻找他们希望我为他们买的游戏。正当真实的陆军遭遇声誉危机时，以虚构或星际世界为基础的战斗和第一人称射击游戏却在蓬勃发展。
Establishing battlefield control. Stand by. Games like StarCraft, Half-Life, and Command and Conquer, Tiberian Sun. Each of which were on the list of top 10 best-selling computer games of 1999. And the games they were looking at were always in the perspective of like a soldier. And that quickly led to an idea that the best way perhaps for the Army to talk to young adults about being a soldier is virtually. Wardinsky began to envision a video game that pulled from popular shooter-style games.
建立战场控制。请准备。诸如《星际争霸》、《半条命》和《命令与征服：泰伯利亚之日》之类的游戏。每一款都名列1999年畅销电脑游戏前十名。他们正在看的游戏总是从士兵的角度出发。这很快产生了一个想法，即陆军与年轻人谈论成为一名士兵的最佳方式或许是虚拟的。沃登斯基开始设想一款借鉴流行射击类游戏的电子游戏。
But instead of the fantastical version of combat featured in many blockbuster titles, Wardinsky's game would support recruitment by giving young people an idea of what the armies really like, as he interpreted it. You really couldn't like take him on an army post and take him through basic training or let them drive a tank. But virtually, you could get past all those limitations and let a child sort of take a virtual test drive of the army. They could do it from their bedroom. They didn't have to go to an army for it. They could do it when it fit their schedule. And so these are the ideas that drove the concept.
但沃登斯基的游戏没有采用许多大片中出现的奇幻战斗版本，而是通过让年轻人了解他所理解的军队真实面貌来支持招募。你真的不能带他去陆军基地带他完成基本训练或让他们开坦克。但在虚拟环境中，你可以克服所有这些限制，让孩子在军队中进行某种虚拟试驾。他们可以在卧室里完成。他们不必为此去陆军基地。他们可以在适合自己时间表的时候进行。所以这些是推动这个概念的想法。
To take the ideas from concept to reality, Werdinsky focused on the details, like the images, sound, and language of the game. But he knew next to nothing about game design. So he brought in some help, a team of Army modelers and simulation experts from the Naval Postgraduate School in Monterey, California. To get a better sense of the Army story
为了将这些想法从概念变为现实，沃登斯基专注于细节，比如游戏的图像、声音和语言。但他对游戏设计几乎一无所以。因此，他带来了一些帮助，一个由来自加利福尼亚州蒙特雷海军研究生院的陆军建模师和模拟专家组成的团队。为了更好地了解陆军的故事
during game development, Werdinsky's team visited bases, filming and studying real-life soldiers and their equipment to make the game's actions, like running, crawling, and gunfire as accurate as possible. But Werdinsky's vision went beyond high-end graphics. He wanted the game to communicate the breadth of opportunities available in the Army, just as a real-life recruiter would. Except with the Army game, it could be hands-on, and at times, mandatory. They were really keenly invested in letting you know that this, while like other shooters in certain respects, was not going to simply leave you to your own pursuit. That's Matthew Thomas Payne, Associate Professor at Notre Dame. He studies the relationship
在游戏开发过程中，沃登斯基的团队参观了基地，拍摄并研究了真实生活中的士兵及其装备，以使游戏的动作（如奔跑、爬行和枪击）尽可能准确。但沃登斯基的愿景不仅限于高端图形。他希望游戏能够传达陆军中可用的广泛机会，就像现实生活中的招募人员一样。只是通过陆军游戏，它可以是亲自动手的，有时是强制性的。他们非常热衷于让你知道，虽然这在某些方面与其他射击游戏相似，但不会简单地让你独自追求。
between the military and video games. They had clear agenda in place, and part of that meant that you were going to go through the drills that a recruit would go through, and that you would along the way understand the values that the Army embraced while playing this game. While putting together the game, Werdinsky and his team developed a series of training modules that taught the players the basics of Army work as they envisioned it, from physical fitness to first aid to target practice. Players were required to pass certain modules before they could hit the battlefield. in their chosen roles.
那是圣母大学副教授马修·托马斯·佩恩。他研究军事与电子游戏之间的关系。他们有明确的议程，其中一部分意味着你将经历新兵将要经历的训练，并且在过程中你会理解陆军在玩这款游戏时所拥有的价值观。在制作游戏时，沃登斯基和他的团队开发了一系列训练模块，按照他们的设想向玩家传授陆军工作的基础知识，从体能到急救再到打靶。玩家必须通过特定的模块才能进入战场完成
He'd sit there and go through courses on combat lifesaver. Okay, soldier, there are injured people out there who need your help. Dealing with, you know, gunshot wounds, dealing with compound fractures and all this kind of stuff. We actually had to back off at one point because we got into like how much morphine to give somebody. That probably got too far down the road. Okay, soldier, remember to treat the most critical casualty first. Am I going to be okay? Werdinsky, a very eat-your-vegetable kind of guy,
他们选择的角色。他会坐在那里参加战斗救生员课程。好吧，士兵，外面有需要你帮助的受伤人员。处理枪伤，处理粉碎性骨折和所有这类事情。我们实际上在某个时候退缩了，因为我们开始讨论给某人注射多少吗啡。这可能走得太远了。好吧，士兵，记住先处理最严重的伤员。我没事吧？沃登斯基是一个非常注重实质的人，
believes that you could put in these arduous boot camp trainings and young people would still play the game. And if that was a turnoff, he didn't really care. The whole undergirdment of the game was these Army values, and if that wasn't interesting to you, we probably weren't that interested in you and you probably weren't that interested in us. The Army game team created a series of detailed maps,
相信你可以加入这些艰苦的新兵训练营，年轻人仍然会玩这个游戏。如果这让人反感，他其实并不在意。整个游戏的基石是这些陆军价值观，如果这引不起你的兴趣，我们可能对你也没那么大兴趣，而你可能对我们也没那么大兴趣。陆军游戏团队创建了一系列详细的地图
vaguely Middle Eastern cities, war-torn hospitals, disputed bridges, that players, once they passed marksmanship and weapons training, could explore, defend, and conquer with their teammates, other teens and young adults from around the country and world, representing the virtual U.S. Army. But the developers had one big looming question, because war can't exist without an enemy. The question was, well, who's, you know, America's the good guys, who are the bad guys? Well, before 9-11, that wasn't a real easy question to address. And so we were looking at narco-terrorists, you know, and people like that to be the bad guys.
含糊不清的中东城市、饱受战争摧残的医院、争夺中的桥梁，玩家在通过枪法和武器训练后，可以与队友、来自全国和世界各地的其他青少年和年轻人一起探索、保卫和征服，代表着虚拟的美国陆军。但开发者们有一个挥之不去的重大疑问，因为没有敌人就无法存在战争。这个问题就是，好吧，谁是，你知道的，美国是好人，谁是坏人？好吧，在911事件之前，这不是一个真正容易回答的问题。因此我们当时在寻找毒枭恐怖分子，你知道的，以及类似这样的人来充当坏人。
After 9-11, that solved itself. It was obviously Taliban and Nekru. And so that made that more straightforward. The enemy in the game wasn't directly called the Taliban. But in 2001, the overwhelming cultural consensus that the Taliban was America's number one real-life enemy, it served as a guiding force as Wardinsky and his team fleshed out the details of their virtual enemy combatants. For instance, the game said it. The operations in the game would be in Afghanistan or Iraq or somewhere like that, and they would be involved with the war on terror, which would be as surprised as they weren't, given that the United States by the time we launched the game was in the war on terror.
911事件之后，这个问题迎刃而解。显然是塔利班和基地组织。因此这让事情变得更加直接。游戏中的敌人并没有直接被称为塔利班。但在2001年，塔利班是美国头号现实生活敌人的压倒性文化共识，成为沃丁斯基和他的团队充实虚拟敌方战斗人员细节时的指导力量。例如，游戏里这样设定。游戏中的行动将会在阿富汗、伊拉克或类似的地方进行，他们将参与反恐战争，这可以说是既在意料之中又在意料之外，因为在我们推出游戏时，美国就已经身处反恐战争之中了。
And playing as the U.S. Army against this enemy, that was the only choice. While in your average multiplayer game, you got to choose which team you're on, in the Army game, you would always be Team U.S. Think of it like a patriotic mirror. Matthew Thomas Payne again. So you really only see yourself as a U.S. soldier. You never played as anyone other than the U.S. Army. Even in a multiplayer setting where Team A is fighting Team B, both Team A and Team B always see themselves as the U.S. soldiers and they always see their opponents as a kind of oppositional force
而扮演美国陆军对抗这个敌人，这是唯一的选择。虽然在你平常的多人游戏中，你可以选择加入哪个团队，但在陆军游戏中，你永远都是美国队。把它想象成一面爱国主义的镜子。马修·托马斯·佩恩再次说道。所以你实际上只把自己看作一名美国士兵。你从来没有扮演过美国陆军以外的任何人。即使在A队与B队对抗的多人游戏环境中，A队和B队也总是认为自己是美国士兵，并且他们总是将对手视为某种对立力量
foreclosing the ability for any of the teams to imagine themselves as an oppositional force force or as terrorist. And it was against this backdrop that Werdinsky began to launch his project, America's Army, the official U.S. Army game. Q menu theme. In May 2002, Werdinsky premiered America's Army at the East. Electronic Entertainment Expo in Los Angeles, one of the biggest industry trade shows in the country.
排除了任何团队将自己想象成对立力量或恐怖分子的可能性。正是在这样的背景下，沃丁斯基开始推出他的项目，即美国陆军，官方的美国陆军游戏。Q菜单主题曲。2002年5月，沃丁斯基在洛杉矶的E3电子娱乐展上首发了《美国陆军》，这是该国最大的行业展会之一。
He worked with a marketing team to make the release into an event that felt like a military operation. And I said, okay, you get us to space, we'll bring the Rasmatans. And they're like, what does that mean? I said, well, we'll show up with the army. Tanks were theatrically placed outside of the venue. soldiers repelled from the ceiling of the convention center holding machine guns, while groups of young people crowded around computers demoing the game. The stunt got coverage from the New York Times, CNN, and the LA Times. America's Army came out on the 4th of July 2002,
他与营销团队合作，将发布会办成了一场宛如军事行动的活动。我说，好吧，你们把我们弄到场地，我们负责带来热闹。他们问，那是什么意思？我说，好吧，我们会带着军队出场。展会场馆外戏剧性地摆放着坦克。士兵们手持机枪从会展中心的天花板上绳降而下，同时成群结队的年轻人挤在电脑周围体验游戏演示。这次特技表演得到了《纽约时报》、《CNN》和《洛杉矶时报》的报道。《美国陆军》于2002年7月4日发布，
and within the first month of release, the game was downloaded more than one and a half million times. It was the first of its kind, a video game by the U.S. Army designed for recruitment. Wardinsky's belief that video games could bring the army to young people had been proven right. The game's success was partly due to Wardensky's dedication to realistic gun design and life-like language of virtual drill sergeants, but America's army offered something else, something none of its competitors could. The game was 100% free. If you had an internet connection, it was yours. It's hard to overstate just how important it was that America's Army be a free-to-play game.
在发布后的第一个月内，该游戏的下载量就超过了150万次。这是同类游戏中的第一款，由美国陆军设计用于招兵买马的电子游戏。沃丁斯基关于电子游戏能够将陆军带给年轻人的信念已被证明是正确的。游戏的成功部分归因于沃丁斯基对逼真枪械设计的执着以及虚拟军士长们逼真的语言，但《美国陆军》还提供了其他东西，这是它的任何竞争对手都无法比拟的。这款游戏是100%免费的。只要你连接了互联网，它就是你的。很难夸大《美国陆军》作为一款免费游玩游戏究竟有多么重要。
Big budget free-to-play games like we have today, right, with Fortnite and other games, didn't really exist. Most games that take multiple millions of dollars to produce, you want to return on investment. The Army doesn't care about that. By the end of 2002, the Army had spent nearly a little bit of two. $11 million on America's Army, according to data obtained by the website GameSpot. It's a budget where Dinsky considers a steal for the Army who, for context, budgeted $55 million for TV ads in 2003 alone. Like they're not in it to make money from the game quite clearly.
像我们今天这样的大预算免费游戏，比如《堡垒之夜》和其他游戏，当时并不真正存在。大多数需要数百万美元来制作的游戏，你都希望获得投资回报。陆军并不在乎这一点。根据网站GameSpot获得的数据，到2002年底，陆军在《美国陆军》上花费了接近1100万美元。沃丁斯基认为对于陆军来说这是一个极其划算的预算，相比之下，仅在2003年，陆军就为电视广告预算了5500万美元。就像很明显地那样，他们参与其中并不是为了从游戏中赚钱。
They're in it to get recruits. They're in it for positive brand recognition or having people think more positively about what a career in the Army might look like. like. But gameplay wasn't limited to those of recruitable age. As a commercial game, America's Army received a rating, T for Teen, which marked the game's content as suitable for players as young as 13 years old. Teen games will have some violence, but there's typically little gore or explicit blood. Now, of course, producers know all of this, and they use ratings to strategically market their games. Teen and titles designed for younger players are our
他们参与其中是为了获得新兵。他们参与其中是为了获得积极的品牌知名度，或者让人们对陆军职业的样貌产生更积极的想法。但是游戏玩法并不局限于达到招募年龄的人。作为一款商业游戏，《美国陆军》获得了T级（青少年级）评级，这标志着该游戏的内容适合13岁及以上的年轻玩家。青少年级别的游戏会包含一些暴力，但通常很少有血腥或露骨的血。当然，制作人深知这一切，他们利用评级来对其游戏进行战略性营销。青少年级以及专为年轻玩家设计的产品是
often sold as family-friendly experiences. This meant that America's Army, the game that promised a true and authentic army experience, was relatively bloodless. Unlike in a real battle, player shot dead fell to the ground without much of a visible wound. Then booted the game back up and started again. I mean, you would see much more kind of graphic detail in even fantasy shooters of the 90s than you would see in something like America's Army. When we talk about military realism, I don't think you're going to design a game that is realistic to a soldier's experience that is going to sell anybody on being a part of that experience because we know that a lot of the experience is absolute boredom, which is punctuated by these moments of horror. Pain says having America's
通常作为适合全家体验的游戏进行销售。这意味着承诺提供真实而地道陆军体验的《美国陆军》相对来说并不血腥。与真实的战斗不同，被击毙的玩家倒地时并没有太多可见的伤口。然后重新启动游戏并再次开始。我的意思是，即使在90年代的奇幻射击游戏中，你也会看到比《美国陆军》中多得多的画面细节。当我们谈论军事写实主义时，我不认为你会设计出一款符合士兵真实体验的游戏，并能说服任何人去成为那种体验的一部分，因为我们知道许多体验都是绝对的无聊，而这种无聊被这些恐怖的时刻所打断。佩恩说，让《美国陆军》
Army rated teen was key to making the game available to its core. demographic. Teens and pre-teens open to considering a future in the U.S. Army. Young people like T.J. Bolcher. He was just 13 years old when he started playing America's Army, about a year after it dropped. He was already interested in video games and curious about the military when he saw a post about America's Army on the website PC Gamer. And the price was right. Pretty much immediately, he got way into it. I was playing every day if I could for several hours a day. In order to play, Bolcher started to make his way through Wardinsky's training modules,
被评为青少年级是让这款游戏能够面向其核心人群的关键。对考虑加入美国陆军未来持开放态度的青少年和前青少年。像TJ·鲍尔彻这样的年轻人。当他开始玩《美国陆军》时，他才13岁左右，大约在该游戏推出一年后。他已经对电子游戏感兴趣，并且在网站PC Gamer上看到一篇关于《美国陆军》的帖子时对军队产生了好奇。而且价格也很合适。几乎立刻，他就深深迷上了它。如果可能的话，我每天都会玩几个小时。为了能够玩游戏，鲍尔彻开始学习沃丁斯基的训练模块，
the ones he hoped would give players an authentic sense of army service. And he loved them. Let's get started. They make you watch basically a slideshow and game on the steps to do first aid and what your role as a medicus should be in combat. Shark may be caused by severe injury or blood loss and disrupts the normal flow of blood through the body. Depending on how well you did, it could take anywhere from a half hour to an hour if you failed the test and had to retake it and rewatch it. This is just pathetic, soldier. Okay. Wow. Yeah. So that's kind of a commitment when you're a 13 years old. It is a super commitment as a young kid.
那些他希望赋予玩家对军队服务真实感的模块。他非常喜欢它们。让我们开始吧。它们基本上让你观看幻灯片，并在游戏中学习如何进行急救以及你在战斗中作为军医的角色。休克可能是由严重受伤或失血引起的，并会扰乱血液在体内的正常流动。根据你表现的好坏，如果你没通过测试不得不重新参加并重新观看，这可能需要半小时到一小时的时间。这简直太糟糕了，士兵。好吧。哇。是的，所以当你13岁的时候，这算是一种承诺。作为一个小孩子，这绝对是一个巨大的承诺。
I found it really interesting that you had to do all this training and even had the ability to train like you were an adult in the Army. After training, T.J. got ready to deploy. You pick a role, whether it's a rifleman, an automatic rifleman, a sniper, and once you pick that role, you're in a team based on what role you pick. That rifleman or sniper then picked a map and a mission to play. In one map, it's your mission to make a preemptive raid on a terrorist training camp. In another map, one of T.J.'s favorites, Team USA had to cross a bridge held by enemy occupants. And it was during this stage of gameplay that the results from those training modules could come back to help or hinder a player.
我发现非常有意思的是，你必须完成所有这些训练，甚至还具备像军队里的成年人一样进行训练的能力。训练结束后，TJ准备部署。你选择一个角色，无论是步枪手、自动步枪手还是狙击手，一旦你选择了该角色，你就会根据你所选的角色加入一个团队。那个步枪手或狙击手随后选择了一张地图和一个任务来玩。在一张地图中，你的任务是对恐怖分子训练营进行先发制人的突袭。在另一张地图中，这是TJ最喜欢的地图之一，美国队必须穿过一座由敌方占领者把守的桥梁。正是在这个游戏阶段，那些训练模块的结果才会回来帮助或阻碍玩家。
Take the medical training, Bolcher mentioned earlier, the one with the final exam. During that module test, players actually had a choice to cheat, which helpful if you couldn't remember all the details in the informational slideshow. But if you cheated on the test to pass the medical training, Wardinsky says it could come back to haunt you in a firefight on that very bridge. Say you're playing medic and a teammate gets shot. And the game announces to all the other players, hey, Joe over here cheated in basic training and medic, and he doesn't know how to save any of you.
以鲍尔彻之前提到的医疗训练为例，就是那个有期末考试的训练。在该模块测试期间，玩家实际上可以选择作弊，如果你记不住信息幻灯片中的所有细节，这会很有帮助。但沃丁斯基说，如果你在测试中作弊以通过医疗训练，这可能会在座桥上的交火中回来困扰你。假设你扮演医务兵，而一个队友中枪了。游戏会向所有其他玩家宣告，嘿，这边的乔在基础训练和医务兵测试中作弊了，他根本不知道怎么救你们任何人。
So the game would keep all that and play it back to a kid at the right moment in time, maybe two years down the road. And the Army message, it wasn't just woven. into gameplay. Looking back, Bolcher remembers the overt marketing and recruitment text included in America's Army pretty vividly. On the landing page of the client before you started the game, they had all their recruiting stuff plastered all over it. What kind of stuff would it say? You know, go, like, go Army, click here if you're interested in joining the Army, learn more about the Army and stuff like that.
所以游戏会记录所有这些，并在恰当的时刻向一个孩子回放，也许是在两年之后。而陆军的信息，不仅仅是织入。进游戏玩法中。回想起来，鲍尔彻对《美国陆军》中包含的公开营销和招募文字记忆犹新。在开始游戏之前的客户端着陆页上，他们到处都贴满了招募的东西。它会说些什么样的话？你知道的，去吧，比如，加入陆军，如果你有兴趣参军就点这里，了解更多关于陆军的信息之类的。
After countless hours of battling as a member of the virtual U.S. Army, Bolcher finished high school and then enlisted in the military for real. He opted for the Marines instead of the Army because it's the branch other members of his family served in. But America's Army still had a significant impact. It definitely influenced my decision to join it. I wanted to be able to do the things that I can do in the game, work as a squad, work as a team, be leadership, all of those things had a heavy influence on me wanting to do that.
作为虚拟美国陆军的一员经历了无数小时的战斗后，鲍尔彻高中毕业，然后真正参了军。他选择加入海军陆战队而不是陆军，因为他的家庭其他成员曾在该兵种服役。但《美国陆军》仍然产生了重大影响。它绝对影响了我加入的决定。我想要能够做我在游戏中能做的事情，小组合作，团队合作，担任领导地位，所有这些事情都对我想要这样做产生了巨大影响。
It's impossible to know how many people joined up because of America's Army. But the player numbers, they show a lot of engagement with the game. In July of 2008, the Guinness World Records named America's Army the most downloaded war video game ever, with more than 42.5 million downloads. For Werdinsky, America's Army was exactly what he had hoped for, a seemingly successful recruitment tool and a chance to get his version of the Army into mainstream media. Beyond anybody's dreams, it won every award you can win. This is an immersion. This is, they're in the Army except for sweating. The Army proved that it could get attention in the commercial gaming industry.
无法确切知道有多少人因为《美国陆军》而参军。但玩家数量显示出对该游戏的高度参与。2008年7月，吉尼斯世界纪录将《美国陆军》命名为有史以来下载量最多的战争电子游戏，下载量超过4250万次。对于沃丁斯基来说，《美国陆军》正是他所希望的，一个看似成功的招募工具，也是一个将他版本的陆军推向主流媒体的机会。超出了任何人的梦想，它赢得了你能赢得的所有奖项。这是一种沉浸感。这就是，除了出汗之外，他们就在陆军里。陆军证明了它能够在商业游戏行业中获得关注。
That good graphics and a free 99 price tag could get Army recruitment messaging in front of millions of eyes, setting the precedent for a relationship between the military and the video game sector that would continue for decades. But not everyone was on board. When we come back, Army games. Meets the Resistance. From the moment it was released in 2002, it also drew criticism from parents and advocates concerned that the project gamified war to a young and impressionable audience. Remember, at the time, America's actual army was at war in Afghanistan and Iraq.
优秀的画面和99美分的免费价格标签可以将陆军招募信息呈现在数百万双眼睛面前，为军队与视频游戏行业之间将持续数十年的关系开创了先例。但并非所有人都赞同。当我们回来时，陆军游戏。遭遇抵抗。从2002年发布的那一刻起，它也招致了父母和维权人士的批评，他们担心这个项目将战争游戏化，呈现在年轻且易受影响的受众面前。请记住，当时，美国真正的陆军正在阿富汗和伊拉克打仗。
Anti-war advocates saw America's army not just as a glorification of war, but as a tool for promoting military violence. There was no shortage of hand-wringing around. Now, well, what does it mean to, like, play war while there's war happening, particularly in these games where they're advertised for having photo realistic graphics and surround sound and military vehicles and weapons that look and kind of fire like the real thing. In 2006, media artist and activist Joseph Dillap began joining America's Army games under the handle dead in a rock. In an act of protest art, Dilap would drop his virtual weapon and begin typing into the game's chat function for everyone to read. In it, he entered the
反战活动人士认为《美国陆军》不仅是对战争的美化，更是宣传军事暴力的工具。周围不乏焦虑之声。现在，好吧，在有战争发生的情况下玩战争意味着什么，特别是当这些游戏被宣传为具有照片般的真实感和环绕立体声以及看起来和开火都像真东西的军用车辆和武器时。2006年，媒体艺术家兼活动家约瑟夫·迪拉普开始以“死在岩石中”为代号加入《美国陆军》游戏。作为一种抗议艺术行为，迪拉普会放下他的虚拟武器，开始在游戏的聊天功能中打字供所有人阅读。在其中，他输入了
name, age, and service branch of every American killed while serving in Iraq. Delap describes this act as a cautionary gesture, a protest to what he described as, quote, this very simplistic representation of warfare. In a wide-ranging 2008 report, the ACLU even accused America's army and the army at large of violating a UN treaty aimed at protecting children from military recruitment. But these critics were no match for the cultural appetite of post-9-11 America. It could have been a situation where you could have had a public, a game plane, consumer group that said, no, thank you, this isn't for us, but that's not what we have.
在伊拉克服役期间阵亡的每名美国人的姓名、年龄和服役军种。迪拉普将此举描述为一个警示姿态，是对他所描述的“这种对战争极其简单化的表述”的抗议。在2008年的一份长篇报告中，美国公民自由联盟甚至指责《美国陆军》和整个陆军违反旨在保护儿童免受军队招募的联合国条约。但这些批评无法与后911时代美国的文化胃口相抗衡。本可以出现这样一种情况：公众、游戏玩家、消费者群体说，不，谢谢，这不是给我们的，但我们得到的并不是那样。
We had instead, yes, this is awesome. Can we have some more of this, please? And so the rest is history, right? Under the leadership of Casey Wardensky, America's Army continued. America's Army's Special Forces was released in 2003. Two years later, America's Army, Rise of a Soldier, dropped on Xbox. Then comics, action figures, and in-person events, like the virtual army experience, a traveling interactive virtual battlefield exhibited in a 10,000 square foot inflatable dome. But by the mid-2000s, the realistic first-person shooter space was radically more competitive. Payne says America's Army's later versions, America's Army 3 and America's Army Proving Grounds,
相反，我们得到的是，是的，这太棒了。能再给我们来点这个吗？所以剩下的就是历史了，对吧？在凯西·沃丁斯基的领导下，《美国陆军》继续前行。《美国陆军：特种部队》于2003年发布。两年后，《美国陆军：士兵的崛起》登陆Xbox。然后是漫画、动作玩偶以及线下活动，例如虚拟陆军体验，这是一个在10000平方英尺充气穹顶中展出的巡回互动虚拟战场。但到了2000年中期，现实的第一人称射击游戏领域的竞争变得更加激烈。佩恩说，《美国陆军》的后期版本，《美国陆军3》和《美国陆军：训练场》，
They struggled to keep up with some of the flashier opportunities posed by other new games. I don't know if there's a change in appetite as much as continuing kind of ratcheting up of what was possible. American Army just really couldn't keep up because of, I think, their correct assumption that they had to remain within certain kinds of representational and simulational parameters. You want to be able to, you know, fire a giant machine gun from. from a helicopter. Like, you don't want to be doing basic training when you could be jumping out of a jet or fighting with your pals in a session of death match over and over again. In 2022, after a two-decade run, America's Army was honorably discharged from the virtual
它们在跟上其他新游戏带来的更耀眼机会方面苦苦挣扎。我不知道这是否是胃口的变化，还是对可能性的不断加码。由于我认为他们做出了必须保持在某些表征和模拟参数内的正确假设，《美国陆军》真的无法跟上。你希望能够，你知道的，从直升机上发射重机枪。当你可以跳出喷气机或者在一场又一场的死斗中与你的死党并肩作战时，你才不想做什么基础训练呢。2022年，在经历了二十年的运营后，《美国陆军》从虚拟
battlefield. The Army officially removed the game from its servers and shuttered the game's website. America's Army creator, Casey Wardensky again. A lot of really good people made that game happen. You know, I'm just the guy who came up with an idea and then made sure everything hung together. But a lot of really good people are in the Army because of that game. As trends in video games changed, so did the Army's approach to using them for recruitment. Major game studios like Electronic Arts and Activision were making Blockbuster titles,
战场上光荣退役。陆军官方从其服务器上删除了该游戏，并关闭了游戏网站。《美国陆军》创造者凯西·沃丁斯基再次发声。很多非常优秀的人让这款游戏得以实现。你知道的，我只是那个想出一个点子然后确保一切凝聚在一起的人。但因为那款游戏，许多非常优秀的人加入了陆军。随着视频游戏趋势的变化，陆军利用它们进行招募的方法也随之改变。像艺电和动视这样的大型游戏工作室正在制作大片，
that targeted the same military-interested audience that the Army coveted. So they pivoted. Instead of making their own games, the Army started to take advantage of opportunities offered by bigger, flashier, more successful games to reach the same objective as America's Army, connecting with potential recruits.
这些大片瞄准了陆军垂涎的那些对军事感兴趣的相同受众。所以他们改变了策略。陆军没有制作自己的游戏，而是开始利用更大、更炫目、更成功的游戏所提供的机会，来达到与《美国陆军》相同的目标，即与潜在新兵建立联系。
The military has been largely opportunistic in the way that it approached video games as a technology. when Halo was a really big property, it wasn't uncommon for recruiters to be part of the game release parties and they would occasionally appear at retail places where people were lining up to buy the games in part because, well, if you like this military space shooter,
军方在将视频游戏作为一种技术来对待的方式上在很大程度上一直是机会主义的。当《光环》成为一个非常大的资产时，招募人员参加游戏发布会并偶尔出现在人们排队购买游戏零售场所并不罕见，部分原因是，好吧，如果你喜欢这种军事太空射击游戏，
you know, maybe you're already predisposed to being interested in the Army as well. Current and former members of the military have also served as subject matter experts for games such as Call of Duty and Tom Clancy's Ghost Recon Breakpoint, consulting on the game's realism and offering player feedback, just as they did internally for America's Army in the early 2000s. And back at Fort Knox, the Army is continuing to build out its outreach efforts in the competitive gaming space. Currently, I'm playing for the United States Army Esports team, and that's my dream to be some sort of organization.
你知道的，也许你已经天然地对陆军产生了兴趣。现役和退役军人也曾担任过诸如《使命召唤》和《汤姆·克兰西：幽灵行动断点》等游戏的题材专家，就游戏的真实性提供咨询并提供玩家反馈，就像他们在2000年代初为《美国陆军》在内部所做的那样。而在诺克斯堡，陆军正在继续扩大其在竞技游戏领域的拓展工作。目前，我正在为美国陆军电子竞技战队效力，成为某种组织的一员是我的梦想。
playing professionally. Today, the video games played by Army Esports soldiers aren't in-house creations like America's Army. Some of them aren't even shooter games at all. Like, have you ever heard of the insanely popular game Rocket League? It's basically cars playing soccer, and the Army Esports team is way into it. The titles they play vary, Apex Legends, Call of Duty, Valorant, Overwatch 2, but they all have one thing in common. incredibly popular with young people and they're huge in the e-sports world,
进行专业比赛。今天，陆军电竞士兵玩的视频游戏不再是像《美国陆军》那样内部制作的作品。其中有些甚至根本不是射击游戏。比如，你听说过火爆全球的《火箭联盟》吗？它基本上就是赛车在踢足球，而陆军电竞队对此非常热衷。他们玩的游戏种类繁多，包括《Apex英雄》、《使命召唤》、《无畏契约》、《守望先锋2》，但它们都有一个共同点：在年轻人中极其受欢迎，并且在电竞世界中占据重要地位，
where about a quarter of those who watch are 20 years old or younger. And as Captain Mimi Mejia, commander of the Army's outreach company, says, some of these young people could make great soldiers today or in the years to come. I do think that people who have skills in gaming can be beneficial to the Army, especially with the way that we see the future of war going right now. it's a lot more technologically advanced. So those types of skills versus, you know, just straight up war fighters is really coming into play right now. And that's why this whole company was stood up to be part of that broader recruitment effort,
其中大约四分之一的观众年龄在20岁或以下。正如陆军外展连连长米米·梅希亚（Mimi Mejia）上尉所说，其中一些年轻人现在或未来几年可能会成为优秀的士兵。我确实认为，具备游戏技能的人对陆军大有裨益，尤其是考虑到我们目前所看到的未来战争的发展方向。它更加依赖技术。因此，与那种单纯的传统战士相比，这些类型的技能现在确实发挥了作用。这就是为什么整个连队被建立起来，作为更广泛招募工作的一部分，
that we wouldn't just have boots on the ground in high schools, but that we would be able to meet people where they're at in these different arenas. I asked the Army how they measure the success of their. e-sports program. Lieutenant Colonel Lindsay Thompson wrote me back. He's commander of the U.S. Army Mission Support Battalion, which oversees Army Esports. Thompson said that the Army Esports team gets about 500 direct responses or sign-ups at
我们不仅要在高中进行地面宣传，还要能够在这些不同的竞技场中与人们相遇。我问陆军他们是如何衡量其电竞项目成功的。林赛·汤普森（Lindsay Thompson）中校给我回了信。他是美国陆军任务支援营的营长，该营负责监督陆军电竞。汤普森表示，陆军电竞队在每次活动中会获得大约500次直接回应或注册。他补充说，
each event. He added that, in opting to participate in these Army Esports activities, members of the public provide personal information. That includes email and phone numbers, which may be used by Army recruiters to, quote, follow up with respondents who have expressed an interest in joining the Army or those that just want information about the Army. But the Army's presence in the esports arena, in person and online, is a tactic some gamers and political critics find insincere or even disturbing.
在选择参与这些陆军电竞活动时，公众成员会提供个人信息。这包括电子邮件和电话号码，陆军招聘人员可能会利用这些信息，引述他的话说，“跟进那些表示有兴趣加入陆军的受访者，或者那些只是想了解陆军信息的人。”但是，陆军在电竞领域的存在，无论是线下还是线上，都是一些游戏玩家和政治批评人士认为不真诚甚至令人不安的策略。
It's the action itself of even trying to recruit what could be a very young audience and the tactics is actually doing so. Does Twitch want to allow this? Showcase the talent and hobbies that soldiers have an outlet for outreach. That's code for recruiting. Yeah. It's a sign of desperation, I think. And it's obviously like incredibly dystopian.
仅仅是试图招募可能是非常年轻的受访者的这种行为本身，以及这样做的策略。Twitch想要允许这样做吗？展示士兵拥有的才能和爱好，作为外展活动的出口。这其实就是招募的代名词。是的，我认为这是一个绝望的信号。而且它显然非常具有乌托邦式的 dystonia（反乌托邦色彩）。
It's horrifying. Some of the strongest blowback came in 2020. Back then, the Army was using Twitch to stream its e-sports team to thousands of young viewers. Yes, the Army in particular is getting a lot of criticism, what's new, for how it's acting on Twitch. For one, they've been scolded by Twitch. Kids as young as 13 can make Twitch accounts. Following reporting by the Nation magazine, streamers and advocates accused the Army of using the platform to surreptitiously steer kids to an Army recruitment form. The Army disputed these allegations, but agreed to remove the links after Twitch flagged them for lacking transparency. And more than 10 years after calling out America's Army, the ACLU was back, this time accusing the Army
这太可怕了。一些最强烈的反对声音出现在2020年。当时，陆军正在使用Twitch向成千上万的年轻观众直播其电竞队。是的，陆军特别受到了很多批评，这并不新鲜，因为它在Twitch上的行为。首先，他们受到了Twitch的训斥。年仅13岁的儿童就可以注册Twitch账号。在《国家》杂志报道之后，主播和倡导者指责陆军利用该平台秘密引导儿童填写陆军招募表格。陆军对这些指控提出了异议，但在Twitch因缺乏透明度而对这些链接进行标记后，同意将其移除。在对《美国陆军》提出质疑十多年后，美国公民自由联盟（ACLU）再次出面，这次指责陆军
ESports team of violating the First Amendment. This was after the team's Twitch channel banned commenters who asked questions about war crimes and other alleged military transgressions. This public concern gamed enough momentum that it even caught the attention of Congress. And I'd like to present this amendment by opening with the stance of the U.S. Marine Corps, which is that war is not a game. In July of 2020, New York Representative Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez, a gamer herself, introduced a draft amendment to the House Appropriations Bill that aimed to ban the military from using funds to maintain a presence on Twitch,
电竞队违反了第一修正案。此前，该队的Twitch频道禁止了那些询问战争罪行和其他所谓军事越轨行为的评论者的发言。这种公众关注积聚了足够的势头，甚至引起了国会的注意。我想以美国海军陆战队的立场开始提出这项修正案，即战争不是一场游戏。2020年7月，纽约州众议员亚历山大·奥卡西奥-科尔特斯（Alexandria Ocasio-Cortez）本人也是一名游戏玩家，她向众议院拨款法案提交了一项修正案草案，旨在禁止军方使用资金在Twitch上维持存在，
other streaming platforms. This amendment is specifically to block recruitment practices and funding for recruitment practices on platforms such as Twitch.tv, which are live streaming platforms that are largely populated by children well under the age of military recruitment rules. Right now, currently children on platforms such as Twitch are bombarded with banner ads that link to recruitment sign-up forms that can be submitted by children as young as a 12 years old. The amendment failed, but today, the U.S. Army Esports team remains dormant on Twitch.
以及其他流媒体平台。这项修正案专门用于阻止在诸如Twitch.tv等平台上的招募做法和招募资金的投入，这些平台是直播平台，其中大部分用户都是远低于军队招募年龄规则的儿童。现在，Twitch等平台上的儿童充斥着横幅广告，这些广告链接到招募注册表格，这些表格甚至可以由年仅12岁的儿童提交。该修正案未获通过，但今天，美国陆军电竞队在Twitch上仍然处于休眠状态。
I think many times the view that young, say, high schoolers get about what military service is, is extremely one-sided. That's Jonathan Hansing, an Army veteran and avid gamer. In 2021, fresh out of his Army service, Hansing got involved with a group called Gamers for Peace, dedicated to confronting recruitment via e-sports and other forms of gaming. It's a branch off of the larger advocacy group Veterans for Peace. The military service members that you do have access to in some of these online communities can only say nice things about their service.
我认为很多时候，年轻的高中生对服兵役的看法是极其片面的。这是陆军退伍军人兼狂热游戏玩家乔纳森·汉辛（Jonathan Hansing）的观点。2021年，汉辛刚结束陆军服役，便加入了一个名为“爱好和平的游戏玩家”（Gamers for Peace）的组织，该组织致力于对抗通过电竞和其他形式的游戏进行的招募。它是更大的倡导组织“退伍军人和平组织”的一个分支。你在其中一些在线社区中接触到的现役军人只能说他们服役的好话。
And as a 13-year-old, the 17-year-old, you don't really. have the perspective or the critical thinking skills to ask yourself, what is the full comprehensive view of what military service is like? Enhancing believes that giving this comprehensive view of what it means to join up, the Army has an obligation to do it. Not just, unlike a philosophical sense to the American people, but to the people you serve with to make sure that you are recruiting high-caliber people who understand the risks and accept those risks with clear eyes. You cannot do that if you are filling kids' heads with an
而作为一个13岁、17岁的孩子，你实际上并没有具备提出以下问题的视角或批判性思维能力：服兵役的全貌究竟是什么？汉辛认为，陆军有义务提供关于参军意义的全貌。这不仅是对美国人民的一种哲学意义上的责任，也是对与你并肩作战的人的责任，以确保你招募的是高素质的人才，他们了解风险并以清醒的头脑接受这些风险。如果你用关于军队的错误愿景塞满孩子们的脑袋，你就无法做到这一点。
incorrect vision of what the military is. And as for America's Army, the forces early foray into commercial gaming, the game has found a new life with a small group of highly dedicated players, including early adopter, T.J. Bolcher. Today, he plays America's Army 2.5, an adapted version of the original game with diehard fans around the world. I couldn't believe what I was seeing when it said that they still had a community and the game was actually running and people were playing on it. T.J. says he actually sees a lot of the same names he played with Back when he started at 13 years old. And a lot of those people are now veterans themselves, just like him.
至于《美国陆军》，作为军队早期涉足商业游戏的尝试，该游戏在包括早期采用者T.J.博尔彻（T.J. Bolcher）在内的一小群高度忠诚的玩家中焕发了新生。今天，他玩的是《美国陆军2.5》，这是原版游戏的改编版，世界各地都有死忠粉。当看到他们仍然有一个社区，并且游戏还在运行、人们还在玩时，我简直不敢相信自己的眼睛。T.J.说，他实际上看到了很多自己在他13岁刚开始玩时一起玩过的老面孔。许多人现在自己也成了退伍军人，就像他一样。
If you were in the Navy, the Marines, the Army, or something like that, you get a special icon in game that made you stand out from everybody else. And that's one of the biggest things I wanted when I was growing up playing this game. Did you end up getting that? I did. Was that a big day? It was a huge day. I was really excited. For now, the Army Esports team. remains quiet on streaming platforms, but continues its work at fan expos and other public events.
如果你曾在海军、海军陆战队、陆军或类似部门服役，你在游戏中会获得一个特殊的图标，让你在其他人中脱颖而出。这是我小时候玩这款游戏时最想要的东西之一。你最后得到了吗？得到了。那是重要的一天吗？那是非常重要的一天。我真的很兴奋。目前，陆军电竞队在流媒体平台上保持低调，但继续在粉丝博览会和其他公共活动中开展工作。
And the e-sports team continues to make its presence known to gamers in the competitive esports sphere too. Extending, shall we say, an outreaching hand in the hopes of building up the next generation of American soldiers. That was producer Caitlin Harrow. Next time on episode four of Hidden Levels, the boom and bust of Machinima, the agony and the ecstasy of making movies inside live multiplayer games. There's so many outtakes I have of me just like yelling at the people the game.
而且，电竞队也继续在竞争激烈的电竞领域向游戏玩家宣示自己的存在。可以说是伸出了援手，希望能培养下一代美国士兵。这是制作人凯特琳·哈罗（Caitlin Harrow）。下一集《隐秘层级》第四集将探讨Machinima的兴衰，以及在实时多人游戏中制作电影的痛苦与狂喜。我有很多未采用的片段，都是我在对游戏里的人大喊大叫。
You know, like, don't kill the guest. We're shooting a bad choice of work. We're recording an interview. This episode was produced by Caitlin Herup. It was edited by Christopher Johnson. Mix, sound design, and music composition by Paul Vikas. Additional mixing by Martine Gonzalez. Series theme by Swan Real and Paul Vikas.
你知道，比如，别杀那个客人。我们在拍……这是一个糟糕的工作选择。我们在录制采访。本集由凯特琳·海鲁普（Caitlin Herup）制作。由克里斯托弗·约翰逊（Christopher Johnson）剪辑。混音、声音设计和音乐创作由保罗·维卡斯（Paul Vikas）完成。额外混音由马丁·冈萨雷斯（Martine Gonzalez）负责。系列主题曲由斯旺·里尔（Swan Real）和保罗·维卡斯创作。
Fact-checking by Graham Hesha. The managing producer for Hidden Levels is Chris Barubei. Hidden Levels was created by myself, Ben Brock Johnson, after reading a study about Tetris reducing the effects of PTSD with power-ups and cheat codes thanks to Team 99% Invisible and Team Endless Threat. 99% Invisible's executive producer is Kathy. To Colstead is the digital director, Delaney Hall is our senior editor. The rest of the team includes Jason DeLeon, Emmett Fitzgerald, Vivian Leigh, Lashemadon, Jacob Medina Gleason, Kelly Prime, Joe Rosenberg, and me, Roman Mars. The 99% of visible logo was created by Stefan Lawrence. The art for this series was created by Aaron Nester.
事实核查由格雷厄姆·赫沙（Graham Hesha）完成。《隐秘层级》的执行制片人是克里斯·巴鲁贝伊（Chris Barubei）。《隐秘层级》由我自己本·布罗克·约翰逊（Ben Brock Johnson）在阅读了一项关于俄罗斯方块借助道具和秘籍减少创伤后应激障碍（PTSD）影响的研究后创建，感谢99%隐形团队和无尽威胁团队。99%隐形团队的执行制片人是凯茜。科尔斯特德（Kathy To Colstead）是数字总监，德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）是我们高级编辑。团队其他成员包括杰森·德莱昂（Jason DeLeon）、埃姆特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）、维维安·李（Vivian Leigh）、拉舍马登（Lashemadon）、雅各布·梅迪纳·格利森（Jacob Medina Gleason）、凯利·普赖姆（Kelly Prime）、乔·罗森伯格（Joe Rosenberg）以及我，罗曼·马尔斯（Roman Mars）。99%隐形标志由斯特凡·劳伦斯（Stefan Lawrence）创作。本系列的艺术作品由亚伦·内斯特（Aaron Nester）创作。
We are part of the Sirius XM podcast family, now headquartered six blocks north in the Pandora building. In beautiful, uptown, Oakland, California. Endless Threat is a production of WBUR, Boston's NPR. The rest of our team tackling Unsolved Mysteries, Untold Histories, and Other Wild Stories from the Internet includes my illustrious co-host, Amory Severson, managing producer Selma To Joshi, editor Meg Kramer, Producers Dean Russell, Grace Tatter, and Frannie Monaghan, and sound designer, Emily Jankowski. See you on Friday. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们是Sirius XM播客家族的一部分，总部现在位于北边六个街区的潘多拉大厦。位于加利福尼亚州美丽的奥克兰上城。无尽威胁（Endless Threat）是波士顿NPR电台WBUR的作品。我们团队的其他成员致力于解决未解之谜、未被讲述的历史以及来自互联网的其他疯狂故事，包括我杰出的联合主持阿莫里·瑟维森（Amory Severson）、执行制片人塞尔玛·托·乔希（Selma To Joshi）、编辑梅格·克雷默（Meg Kramer）、制片人迪安·拉塞尔（Dean Russell）、格蕾丝·塔特（Grace Tatter）和弗拉尼·莫纳汉（Frannie Monaghan），以及声音设计师艾米丽·扬科夫斯基（Emily Jankowski）。周五见。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。